how did you know when you met your wife
that that was it man was that hard was
that a weird it was definitely hard you
know what I'm saying my [__] was because
you were I'm sure you was easy to date
oh I thought I was talking about my dick
anyway
um I truth be told yeah how did you know
like this is I found my wife
I walked in uh to a store three days
after I got separated from my previous
wife
and I saw this this girl and I thought I
thought she was like 24 or something I
was 28 at the time she was 19. I didn't
know this and uh yeah and we had a she
worked at a smoothie shop oh God I
[__] love that bro and she was
grinding she busting her ass she's in
college she's doing all this other [__]
and um yeah man she was really just
super duper sweet and I went back to the
same smoothie shop every every every day
for two weeks and she wasn't there oh
and I was like writing music about her
like a [__] creep and I was like
right I just like was so inspired like I
don't know she was just so beautiful she
was breathtaking so I go back every day
in the morning and in the night in case
which shift I don't know and then I go
and I'm like befriending like all the oh
and there's a bunch of bad [__] that
work there and they all think I'm coming
to see them
yo it's crazy like and I remember the
manager was this gay dude and he was
leaving oh now he trying to smash dude
I bought him some chocolates because he
was leaving oh I'm sure so I was like I
was just like I'm gonna be the nicest
[__] I mean I am a nice guy but
I was I'm gonna be extra so she's
hearing about me and she was and she
everybody thought I was there to see
like a different [__] but like she
didn't know and then if she finally
broke two weeks go by and I was like I'm
giving up I go there one night and she
wasn't there and I was like I gotta take
a piss I go take a piss I walk out and I
go to pay for my [__] and I just hear
hey Bobby and I turn around it was this
[__] angel
and I was like oh my God this is it and
my heart was just beating out of my
chest like bro like [__] crazy for
real and it's like man I've gone through
a lot man and I just [__] I'm getting
publicly divorced and just all this
crazy [__] and it's just so difficult
and here's this like Angel and so I'm
talking to her
and she's so [__] supervisor on a
what like a uh smooth like some of it
smoothly places or yeah [__] no she was
looking bad as [__] had her hair all
parted she wasn't looking stupid oh yeah
and then um she's in [__] leggings
and I was like oh my God I'm talking to
her and then she's just so sweet and
she's just talking to me and I'm telling
her about things I have going on she's
like that's so cool you know sometimes
me and my boyfriend no and I was like
what [__] bro sounds like a piece of
[__] yo literally I was like yo this
[__] sucks man what the [__] you got
a boyfriend but I didn't say it like
that I was like oh I was like no way
that's so tight like what's his name
what's his [__] name [__] you better
tell me his [__] name right now I
can't even hear his name oh I don't know
yeah it's a whole thing so she says this
[__] and then
so then I come back I come back like a
week or no a couple days later and I see
her again and what happened and I I was
just like I just talking to her I was
like telling her about all these cool
new things happening in my life oh yeah
definitely and I was just like man like
we should be friends
and she's like tell me our friends no no
she was like yeah for sure and I had
this whole you don't understand like I'm
not joking I like rehearsed for 48 hours
the whole conversation how it was gonna
go how I was gonna get her number oh my
God and then play the long waiting game
because she was worth it you know like I
was like okay we're gonna wait we're
gonna figure this out so
I had this whole thing and I was like we
should be friends and then I start to do
my Spiel she's like yeah I could just
give you my number and I was like oh my
God I don't even have to do I'd have to
do anything so I'm like Okay cool so I
get her number and when did you text her
dude I [__] texted her that night
what I don't give a [__] I'm you're
gonna [__] it up I put my dick on the
table bro I'm not scared of [__] you be
you 100 and they're either gonna accept
you and love you for who you are or
they're [__] not they're not and
that's what I'm saying no that's a real
I mean they're not for you maybe I I
yeah you gotta be yourself bro like be
you in a [__] relationship that's why
it's so [__] when two people get
together on a [__] date and they're
not they're lying they're being them
like I'll be on the first day I'll be
like damn [__] I just ripped ass in the
bathroom wow I'm like that's who I am I
like me and my wife on our first date I
was like I'm not in in a weird way I was
just like do you want children one day
she was like yeah I was like oh dope do
you see yourself getting married I'm
like what's up you super religious she's
like no I believe in something like an
energy or something Universe I'm like
okay I asked those important questions
because most people don't and then five
years [__] later they're getting
divorced because they never talked about
them in the first place yeah so
anyways [__] rubbing a gemstone on
her vulva
but yeah they get weird like that so
dude so you knew and how long after that
did you get engaged well the crazy thing
is super duper long story short
I created this like fake release party
for a mixtape called Bobby Tarantino 2
that just so happened to be on St
Patrick's Day but it was really
basically The Great Gatsby are you
familiar with the Great Gatsby so I
created this whole party just to invite
this business yeah with all her all her
friends
and then she ends up bringing her
boyfriend no yeah it was crazy so she
brings her boyfriend and the dude comes
in and he's like oh Roger can I have a
picture with you and immediately I was
like Swedish
is that Swedish did I just do Sweden I
think so no students like this yeah or
is that more German I don't think
whatever I'm not good with [__] like
if I do an Irish when I do editors sound
kind of Jamaican at the same time I'm
gonna do Irish man yeah anyway [__]
whatever bro long story short she she
she didn't say with that guy
because what did it take and were you
lucky flirting with her what was
happening um I flirted with her but she
never flirted back wow that was that was
beautiful yeah because I was like [__]
I want to take you on on a private
helicopter to San Diego and [__] at the
party yeah I'm like playing I'm playing
pool
that's gangster yeah
I wasn't like yo you want to go see my
[__] redhead collection the [__] what
you mean murderer hey [__] you want to
go to private jet what the [__] you're
right all right anyway yeah you're right
right you're right but yeah I was
definitely flirting with her a little
bit but I was respectful I wasn't like
[__] this dweebed like it wasn't like
right right and then she just like I I
they just that happened she just saw a
man I'm gonna be real she was dating no
she was dating a boy they [__] went
to high school together and [__] and
then she saw a man I was like what's
good
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one